this app
handled more than 15 trillion dollars of
transactions last year
that's more than mastercard and an
amount of money that's similar to the
european union's gdp
it also has more than 900 million users
in china
people use alipay on buses and taxis
to pay their utility bills shop in
stores and online
and even to buy insurance and make
investments
and yet many americans may have never
heard of it and it's huge
in china the alipay app is essentially
a financial supermarket that allows you
to do everything on your mobile phone
alipay's parent company ant group is
getting global attention in 2020.
its combined ipos in hong kong and
shanghai could be one of the largest
listings ever
as ant is aiming for a market valuation
in excess of 200 billion dollars that
means it may sell more than 20 billion
dollars in shares when it goes public
so what is ant and how did it become so
big
[Music]
it all started with jack ma the
flamboyant chinese businessman who's
known for his inspirational speeches
it's not about the money it's about the
dreams extravagant performances at
company parties
and of course co-founding alibaba more
than two decades ago
which has since become a half-trillion
dollar online shopping giant
alibaba is like a mix of amazon
ebay and paypal also with a dash of
google
but it handles more business on its
shopping sites than any other company in
the world
when alibaba was just starting out it
created alipay as an escrow service to
hold money from buyers and release the
funds to sellers
after the goods had been sent and
received this built trust between
merchants and buyers
and helped to pave the way for the
e-commerce industry boom in china
not that many people in china have
credit cards compared to the us
with alipay most people draw funds
directly from their bank accounts and
make cashless electronic payments
without needing to use credit cards in
china you barely see anyone
use cash anymore whether it's to buy a
soda
or a pack of cigarettes people buy
things with qr codes and facial
recognition
in less than five years alipay has
expanded to become a ubiquitous app that
touches other parts of life
today ant group encompasses not just
alipay but a broader range of financial
services including microlending
insurance and one of the largest money
market funds in the world
called you about so it's a really
flexible tool that gives the
average chinese consumers and small
business owners
who have long been ignored by the major
banks a taste of what it's like to be
able to invest
and save money and to get financing to
fund
operations and all of these are done
just through
their smartphones almost instantly
but the rapid growth event has drawn
scrutiny from banks and regulators as
previously reported by the journal
some chinese banks were earlier
concerned that and could take away their
deposits and reduce how much cash people
use
ant is trying to shed its image as a
disrupter of china's banking sector
this year the company dropped the word
financial services from its name
in order to rebrand itself as more of a
tech company
it also partners with many banks that
fund the loans it makes and has made its
money market fund less risky
regulators especially the central bank
they are very concerned about potential
liquidity risk
in one single fund on the uofl platform
the problem is if all investors in this
fund decide to draw
the money at the same time it could
cause
a huge liquidity risk and even damage
the
stability of china's financial system
and responded quickly to regulators
concerns by imposing caps on how much
people could invest
and opening the platform to rival funds
while ants may
have been a bit reluctant to do that to
some degree
its cooperation with the government
really
is crucial because in china very few
business can succeed without
blessings from the regulators outside
china ants attempts to expand have
sometimes gotten entangled in politics
in 2017 anne tried to buy u.s money
transfer company moneygram
but the deal was scuttled by u.s
officials because of national security
concerns
that was a really big blow to anne's
ambition to
in the u.s which is a very large and
potentially lucrative market
and this time ant's dual ipo with
alibaba will bypass
new york a person familiar with the
company said ant never intended to go
public in the u.s
it has its eyes on india and southeast
asia where consumers and businesses are
under banked similar to those in china
but ant's plans aren't to launch alipay
in those markets
and never intends to serve consumers
outside of china
by alipay directly their approach is to
provide some tech or
operational expertise in some mobile
payment startups
in those markets but they don't really
run this business in-house
and since ant has already captured the
biggest market in the world
it's been laying the groundwork to
follow the millions of chinese tourists
who go abroad every year
the company has increased partnerships
with retailers and restaurants overseas
while the pandemic has stifled much of
global travel this year
the company is not seeing a slowdown of
online shopping and cashless payments in
china
though ant will make global headlines
when it hits in hong kong and shanghai
it may remain a household name only in
china
[Music]